looking for the perfect gift for the
golfer in your life the pga tour
superstore who is sponsoring this next
segment has something for everyone
including some incredible giveaways
welcome to the pga tour superstore where
inside this store you're gonna find
great gifts for every player on your
list we've got luxury items clothing
items like bad birdie we even have
stocking stuffers now if you have a hard
time finding that perfect gift be sure
and check out their online holiday gift
guide
[Music]
all right this is incredible beginning
december 10th it is 12 days of giveaways
visit our website
8newsnow.com for your chance to win
great daily prizes daily prizes like
this yeti cooler that will keep your
drinks hot and cold out on the golf
course the bluets series 2 pro
rangefinder it dials in your distances
and makes club selection easy then we
have the garmin approach s10 golf watch
it provides yardages to the front back
and middle of the green as well as
hazards and dog legs not sure what to
get that player on your list you can't
go wrong with a pga tour superstore gift
card or if you're new to golf or want to
improve your game how about a three pack
of 45 minute lessons the titleist pro v1
golf ball designed to deliver longer
distance even more green side spin
control and softer feel the perfect
putting mat featuring two hole training
and guaranteed to dramatically improve
your putting in a few short minutes
check this one out the bar stool golf
americana stand bag from bar stool
sports it features a five-way top with
integrated handle plus a quick acting
stand system
you could win a ping driver the driver
is unique by having an adjustable center
of gravity with weight optimized
features throughout all while having a
high forgiveness threshold or how about
this an rtx wedge from cleveland which
delivers enhanced control more spin and
unmatched durability to last you round
after round you can even win this
taylormade black spider putter and i
think the perfect way to end the day is
by having me sync a putt
[Music]
i made it to win any of these great
items you saw from the pga tour
superstore head to eight newsnow dot com
slash contest for our 12 days of
giveaways and thanks to the pga tour
superstore for sponsoring this segment
rocky
nice fun jc